meaning a motivator unos minutos de
consumo not collectible both of our
articles now I had the reputation of the
time of this Matt Jameson in those days
we were still trying to define what a
computer game was we had the sets we had
the Cowboys the other horses with
everything new
I started at Nintendo in 1981 it was
really just the five or six of us Chucky
Cheese it was an arcade man screening as
restaurant in fact the day wheel
I knew he'd screwed up the place wasn't
big enough
around 1981 this arcade cabinet appeared
now if you played this game it was said
that you would have seizures bits of
amnesia night terrors and also just a
complete desire to continue playing this
game
[Music]
they're Veronica's yo game attends my
life thank you for making the Hobbit all
those years ago Hobbit game did and
still does mean a great deal of me
wasn't expecting to change an industry
I'm a players player I love to play
games the connection that I had with
players was that shared love of just
gaming come over here one of the
greatest video game players who ever
lived
he just quit knows it he just finally
walked off into the sunset I was known
as the first champion a street fighter
and the feeling was just incredible now
my passion is family that's my life now
and if I had to turn the clock back and
do it all over again I would not change
a thing my task was write the best text
adventure computer game ever and I did I
never really thought the mad dog would
have a legacy but its iconic
nobody's ever seen anything like it
[Music]
over
[Music]